the Joe Rogan experience well it's
always weird when you see somebody lean
into something and it's not really them
and they become what people want of them
you know you in yeah you like a great
example in comedy was Kinnison Kinnison
when he made it everyone he wanted to
lay these gigantic lines of coke for him
apparently like how it's him it's him
he's here right this is laid some giant
line of coke and he would joke around
about it like I had to do it oh and you
know he would do you know a giant line
yeah take a [ __ ] heart attack right I
can't not live in right I think because
then then yes they'll stop trusting it
right right but you become a caricature
you come this thing like Dice Clay is
another example like Dice Clay used to
be that used to be one part of his act
his name's Andrew Andrew silverstein so
he would do his act and then the dice
man was a character that he would do but
people loved it so much when he would do
that character that the character became
his whole Act and then he became the
character where you see him in real life
he's wearing like weightlifting gloves
and you know is walking around on a
Gold's Gym t-shirt he became that guy
he's hilarious still but he's that guy
now he's kind of out the back side of
that when you say in what way well now
he's like acting and things he does and
not well yeah but he still does the same
kind of stand-up really if you go see
him it's still hilarious irreverent just
a complete like not of this era well let
me ask you a question because I am I
think it's interesting I think in that
vein like if you look at Howard Stern
who I've met only a couple times but I
had I found him to be like extremely
extremely thoughtful guy like and I
don't mean that he just was very very
intelligent
yeah that's again but he's also like um
I don't know the conversation we have
mutual friends and I and I and I really
enjoyed talking to him like I thought I
thought like oh there's nothing tricky
about him at all he's really like down
in his shoes he's interested he actually
asked question I mean some people you
meet
my god they're talking in a mirror that
you're you were a mirror and they're
just looking at themselves while they
speak to you they're waiting for you to
get done talking to the guitar yeah yeah
but he but I think what I think is
really interesting is like so Howard
imagine imagine the pressure because I I
grew up in the Baltimore area he was on
DC radio he was on DC 101 I remember
that
the shock of him literally and imagine
you know the pole to deliver on what
you've built which was obviously you
know a huge audience that wanted this
thing to me it's really interesting and
impressive that Howard's kind of and I'm
saying like I know and I don't know him
but watching it to me this idea that
he's kind of said hey look I I you know
I'm I'm gonna be honest about where I'm
at and in some measure I'm gonna say
there's things I've done I regret
there's ways I've treated certain people
in the interests of the show that I'm
kind of I'm kind of done with that I
don't really want to be that guy and in
some measure you know he's kind of
saying to his audience like you got to
deal with me where I am now yeah you
know what I mean
now I it's not like there's like a huge
risk in that because his audience is
gigantic right
what's also he's so successful and so
universally praised as being the most
important figure in the history of radio
mm-hmm like there's no one who does like
what I do podcasts there's no a gigantic
debt of gratitude to Howard Stern the
fact that you know he was getting fined
by the FCC me I mean they were hundreds
of thousands of dollars he kept getting
fired from radio stations we kept doing
of doing it the way he did it and it
changed the way people do talk radio
honestly the fact that we can even the
fact that we've talked as long as we've
talked up to now is a function of him
proving that there was a tolerance for
long forms basically you know what I
mean I mean it's like people knock on
Netflix or whatever I'm like I'm like
anything there's an amazing thing going
on in the world right now which is
people are people are re
reproving or reconnecting with the fact
that for all of what goes on on Facebook
and Instagram and Twitter and all this
[ __ ] like the truth is people people
like and have the appetite for and their
brains enjoy longer form conversations
yes and longer form stories more than
then it was assumed they did you know
and I mean and like popular culture
feeds us a lot of like fast food and
xanax in like a speedball of of you
can't handle anything you don't want
anything more than then literally like a
little bit of junk food with a little
bit as an excuse just want to lie on
your couch and watch someone else save
the world that's I know that's all you
want but that in that is not true and I
think like you know you look at things
like like from peaky blinders to
Chernobyl to like the Ken Burns Civil
War series like we're going through this
thing where people are realizing like no
that's not actually true people actually
like you my pal Dax
you know Shepard who's got a great radio
show people like to listen to people
have actual conversations well they're
also listening in it's a new way of
ingesting entertainment like you're
getting it in your car you're getting it
in your ears when you're at the gym yeah
well you're on the subway or bus or
plane and it's you're getting the
stimulating long-form conversations that
maybe maybe people didn't even know they
wanted you know yeah I agree I agree a
great conversation with someone so it's
like you get to have that conversation
without participating right right and
and and Stern definitely was like we're
talking about before and after like I
and there was talk radio but that but it
kind of starts there I think I think you
you started to be like I can listen this
guy for a long time yeah he broke
through the membrane like you're talking
about Hendricks entering into a new
dimension of sounds he broke through the
membrane of talk radio and what he's
doing now is well now he's a man in his
60s who's extremely wealthy and he has
some I'm sure some regrets as you were
talking about the things that he's done
the past and said in the past
and it's also like this is who he is now
he's not going to pretend right that
he's just wants to bring strippers in
and have him ride the city and every day
and when people get upset that he's
changed well I hope you changed too man
yeah I hope everybody changed oh that's
what I mean I admire I mean true it's
true it's it's not quite Dylan when he's
24 and being anointed plugging in a
guitar but I do think it's when people
sort of go hey I'm gonna I'm gonna be
where I am yes and and you got to deal
with it right that's positive I think
well it's definitely better than leaning
into it and being what people want you
to be yeah and be struggling with that
and tortured by that I actually think
most of the most of people who I think
that mostly ends up badly yes yes yeah I
think whenever you don't go with whoever
you actually are and whenever you don't
acknowledge that whoever you actually
are has changed you know if you're
growing and learning and having these
epiphanies in these realizations about
yourself and where you fit into your own
life and how you've interacted with
people in your life you're not making
adjustments and you're only doing it
that way because you think that's what
people expect of you well you're you're
prisoner to your own first incarnation
yeah you know the first thing that
people saw and that was Kenna says oh
he's a kind of a prisoner to that
forever yeah it acknowledged it yeah
it's why it's why anybody who and it's
not even act to anybody anybody who can
who keeps doing interesting things
through phases is even more impressive
[Applause]